frame rates above 60 fps ultra wide
resolutions and better ray trace
reflections these are some of the unique
benefits gamers will get when playing
marvel spider-man's pc release on their
powerful gaming rigs
but as cool as all these features are i
already personally experienced a great
looking and running version of
spider-man on my ps5 what i haven't had
the chance to do is play it on the go
until now so screw all those fancy
features and say hello to spider-man
running on the steam deck
[Music]
but is it a good experience the answer
is mostly a big old thumbs up but with a
few caveats before we start i want to
address that everything we talk about
here is based on our time with a
pre-release version of the game sony
told us up front that they are still
working on optimization and warned us
about certain issues they plan to fix in
fact we got a big fat update just a few
days before this video launched offering
some major improvements so it's possible
some of the issues we talk about will be
improved down the line in future patches
let's get right into the good news which
is that spider-man on steam deck is a
really solid experience the majority of
the game swinging around the city
beating up bad guys doing side
activities all comfortably hits frames
above 30 fps sadly we couldn't get the
game to hit 60fps even at the lowest
settings and using dynamic resolution as
well as upscale methods like amd's fsr
2.0 set to ultra performance although
considering what it does to the image
even if it did hit 60fps you probably
wouldn't want to use it anyways but
we'll touch more on fsr 2.2 in a moment
so forget 60fps and instead look to
target 30. the thing is like spiderman
himself the frame rate likes to swing
around and fluctuate wildly which
creates a pretty unpleasant experience
while playing the simple solution is to
lock the game to 30 fps normally to do
this you'll need to set the resolution
to exclusive full screen and then you
get the refresh rate option but on steam
deck it is not accessible thankfully
there is a simple fix using steam deck's
built-in fps limiter open up the quick
access menu go to performance set the
frame rate limit to 30 and you're all
set smooth 30fps web swinging in the
palm of your hand sure you might miss
the 60fps especially if you're coming
from the ps5 or playing on a desktop but
considering that the original ps4
version of spider-man was locked to 30
fps and therefore designed around that
frame rate playing on the steam deck
doesn't feel like a compromised
experience at least when you're
spider-man there are a few sections in
the game where you play as peter parker
or mary jane in indoor environments with
higher detail and here the frame rate is
less stable fluctuating from 30 fps down
to 25 just enough to be noticeable and
annoying but because the gameplay in
these parts is mostly just walking
around it's not a deal breaker same goes
for the cutscenes which usually hit 30
but can dip in spots this is where we
return to our upscale methods turning on
fsr 2.0 to quality mode does fix this
right up locking everything to 30fps
but it does come with ghosting and other
visual oddities you'll have to
compromise with if you choose to turn it
on
sony did tell us the current build
offers preliminary support for fsr 2.0
and further development is ongoing for
image quality improvements so it's
possible fsr 2.0 might be more effective
in the future and look better the other
upscale option is insomniac games
temporal injection called igti which
switches between multiple upscale
algorithms including fsr 2.0 personally
i didn't notice much of a difference in
image and performance between the two on
the steam deck so take your pick but
what about the rest of the graphic
settings the sweet spot seems to be
medium across the board it creates a
pretty good looking image on the steam
deck's 800p screen dropping down to low
didn't really give any significant boost
to performance to be worth the loss in
visuals and going higher would cause the
game to crash
once you get everything all set up the
game looks pretty nice on the steam deck
cut scenes appropriately scale to the
16x10 screen filling up everything
nicely although menus do not but it's
less noticeable speaking of menus they
mostly play pretty well on the tiny
handheld screen although i do find that
text can be a little all over the place
in spots sometimes it's nice and large
and easily readable and other times it
can be pretty tiny but i'll say that
compared to some other games where i
struggled with the ui being scaled down
to such a tiny size i didn't feel that
way with spider-man and found it to be a
pretty natural fit on the handheld so
should you play spider-man on your steam
deck
abso-freaking-lutely small performance
issues aside the game feels like a
perfect fit for the portable pc it plays
great and the nature of the open world
makes it really easy to just turn on and
do a few quick side activities during
lunch in fact i made the effort to spend
most of my time with the pc version of
spider-man on the steam deck and despite
having already 100 of the game twice and
thinking i didn't really need to touch
it again i found myself having a great
time playing it on the handheld